this 23 million
home sits high in the hollywood hills it
has five bedrooms an
infinity pool a roof deck and three two
one
all right mikey ready and a seal miser
what's up everybody
it's ennis here welcome to another
episode ennis is a youtube personality
who's been given the keys to some of the
world's most expensive homes which he
shares with his more than eight hundred
thousand subscribers
all right everyone here we are at the
entry we have this massive 12 foot
pivot thor his channel sees roughly 15
million views a month
each episode earns thousands of comments
but ennis
isn't trying to sell these mega mansions
i'm not a good salesman
i i don't enjoy selling it at all what i
do is
if this is a great home i'm going to
make sure people see that this is a
great home
ennis isn't typically hired to film but
he is cashing in on these listings in
views
lucrative home tours like these are
blowing up on youtube
shaking up how luxury real estate is
discovered and in some cases
sold
all right let's go guys we got a good
flow let's keep going
[Music]
ennis starts his shoots with a quick
walk through of the home looking for the
kind of details he knows his viewers
want to see
little things like this
the owner the designer the architect he
wrapped
this steel column which could have
looked a little industrial and kind of
naked
with this new newspaper uh wallpaper so
when the cameras do start rolling
all right when he's ready to show his
audience how the point one percent
really live beautiful italian porcelain
tiles fireplace right here
it's double-sided i mean downtown los
angeles is literally your backdrop
from your living area this is incredible
he's meticulous about planning out the
path his tour will take
spacing out the major rooms and
revealing features along the way
to keep viewers watching all right plan
come in
entry porcelain tiles cantilever
natural light living rooms on the side
but first let's go to this wing
office cool it's a process that he and
his crew have honed over the two years
he's been posting home tours
in that time his subscriber count has
exploded
he has about 28 times more subscribers
than he did at the start of 2020.
he now posts a new episode each week
this week we're in lake tahoe california
today we're at 53 west 53rd but ennis
didn't always have access to these
multi-million dollar listings
he and friend mikey ayers just set out
to film any high-end house an agent
would let them into
hey guys so we are happy through the
tour just make sure to subscribe to our
channel
the goal build ennis's profile as a real
estate agent
so i wanted to get my name out there as
a new agent
and i figured if i can do videos that
showcases my knowledge
and construction and houses people will
see that
they will feel like i could be a good
representation for you know for their
real estate needs and they would work
with me but as the level of production
increased and enes's channel gained more
viewers
he realized i no longer want to work as
a real estate agent
so he quit to focus on youtube full time
and he's making more money doing so
ennis is bringing in anywhere from 50 to
100
dollars a month from youtube ad revenue
alone putting him on track to bring in
more than one million dollars this year
if the growth of his channel continues
at its current pace some could argue
that that's a good amount of money
at the same time we do reach 14 15
million people
a month with average retention of seven
to eight minutes
i mean we are a network we're not a
little youtube channel that gets views
and to be honest with you i think we're
underpaid in addition to ad revenue
ennis is now
making money from real estate agents who
pay him to showcase their properties
we have the bar seating right here those
fees can reach five figures
but they aren't necessarily the norm
he's not getting paid to film this home
about the tortoise stunning modern home
right beside me
i've been offered obscene amounts of
money
money that was literally hard for me to
be like no
to shoot homes that are not bad if i
cannot go there
and be enthusiastic about that listing i
will not
shoot i don't care how much they pay us
end of the conversation
[Music]
ennis isn't the only option though his
channel is part of a growing trend
they call this the james bond office
this is by definition the perfect
tribeca
law there clearly has been a trend for
home tours
and it's been excellent sally forrester
jones has been a listing agent for more
than 30 years
showing and selling homes like this one
now sally is giving youtube
personalities access
it is very hard to provide that detail
other
than you know a buyer coming through the
home in my
giving them an actual tour this is as
close as i'm going to get
to having that kind of experience for a
buyer
now this room also has these sliding
glass doors opening up to the front
entry
but handing over the keys isn't without
risks potential buyers watching these
videos see ennis first
not sally and some might not like all
the details of their future home
being viewable online you have the
king-size bed position on this side
the first experience was you know just a
little bit unnerving only because it was
the first experience i had not worked
with him before
i trusted but there's a little bit of
anxiety for the first time
she's now worked with ennis more than
half a dozen times she says she gives
him free reign of the properties because
he knows his stuff
and the views don't hurt either what i'm
looking for is
the interest the excitement and the
right eyeballs in the end or enough of
the right eyeballs that we
do get the property sold and we also
have these chains and windows underneath
the cantilever
complementing the natural light
there is of course a lot more that goes
into selling a home than a tour
in person or on youtube but these tours
have spurred interest in the properties
it has actually really produced uh
you know calls showings and and interest
in a particular property
even though most of the viewers are not
really truly buyers
beautiful hardwood floors complemented
with the built-ins on the right-hand
side
i love the wallpaper they used here for
ennis all viewers are welcome
his focus is on growing his audience and
showcasing homes he knows they'll be
excited to tour
like this one this is everything what
people want to see about hollywood hills
glass doors opening up incredible views
infinity edge pool the whole indoor
outdoor floor
i would say we will at least get this
video in front of
half a million people in less than 30
days and looking at his recent view
counts
he's probably right yeah we've literally
been in like one-fifth of the homes we
see
right now not a joke all right let's go
you